hi there it's me again mr. wonderful
coming to you from the tumultuous world
of money disputes the stress the
bitterness the heartache I'm here to
sweep all that baggage away by helping
you find resolution so let's do just
that I've got a video here from Dustin
with a dispute of course let's listen to
what he has to say hey Kevin my name is
Dustin and I have a dispute with my
business partner on a podcast that we
shot we started shooting and went from
like 100 views to a thousand views to
over 2,000 views and then we got
advertisers and sponsors and almost as
soon as the money started coming in my
partner kind of got greedy and then
basically tried to fire me and I told
him I was like you can't really fire
your partner you can buy me out or
compensate me for my half but you can't
really fire me and then you just went
blank on me now I just want to get
compensated for the time and the money
that I put into the business and I need
your help this is a really interesting
situation what Dustin has created or
co-created could be very very valuable
but I need more information like is
there a contract is there a real
partnership so I've got him waiting on
video that's the nice to meet you nice
to meet you as well so Dustin keep pasta
hombre what happened here so he asked me
to join the podcast just to get some
traction they couldn't get it off the
ground and so there was a meme of me and
you may have seen it me and a girlfriend
of mine at a Astros game and it went
viral multiple times with different
sayings and stuff so basically the first
show that I did went over 250 views and
that was just organic and he asked me to
do it again and the next show that we
did we got to about 500 views and he
asked me to be his partner and we ended
up finalizing it 45 55 now quick
question right out of the gate everybody
wants to know including me do you have a
contract is there anything on paper or
is it just two dudes with a podcast
pretty much you guys with a podcast
there's a lot of text messages back and
forth but no formal contract or anything
like that how do you feel about that
in hindsight like a complete idiot I'm
gonna try and help you but you when you
form a business particularly when
revenue is gonna come in you need
something in writing how much money in
total have you put into it so far about
three hundred and fifty dollars
is there an amount of money a dollar
amount that if he wrote you a check and
gave it to you and left your likeness
there and just kept building the
business that you'd be okay with sixty
seven thousand dollars all right Dustin
you put 350 bucks up and now you want
sixty seven thousand back connect the
points for me
so that's based on to advertisers one
that I brought to the company to the
show that it's four hundred dollars a
show advertised with us which is eight
hundred dollars a week eighty-three
thousand dollars over two years which if
I was going to sell my business I want
two years of revenues and that's after
the production fees you know fifteen
thousand six hundred so sixty seven
thousand dollars that's not unreasonable
you're sounding pretty savvy now I
thought you might have been a little
naive not to have a contract at least
you know how to value the business the
problem is you have no leverage right
now without a contract it's hard to
fight the legal battle and the courts
are jammed up because of all the Cova
stuff and this is not big enough to get
a lawyer that's a contingency player
involved it's just not enough dollars
all right Dustin you have an option here
you can send them a cease and desist
letter tell them to stop using your
likeness and profiting from it without
compensating you you can use the
leverage of that letter to show you're
serious and then negotiate a settlement
on what you're really owed in the equity
piece of this I think the number should
be half you know fifty five forty five
you could settle for forty five percent
of sixty seven thousand and feel pretty
good about it because he did do some
work to would you take half of that I
would I think that's fair at this point
and lastly maybe you just start from
scratch and do it yourself and take all
the ownership and control all the
revenues and go where you want to with
it what about that idea I think it's
fantastic idea if you can build up a
franchise podcasting is the future it's
a huge aspect of digital marketing now I
think you should get behind your own
podcast thank you so much Kevin
take care I've got a question came in on
the email transom from Elissa let's read
it
hi mr. wonderful I work as a retoucher
for an apparel company in LA making
twenty bucks an hour my boss asked me to
model for a photoshoot so I went ahead
but I did expect to be paid as much as
the agency models they use these models
are paid twelve hundred dollars for an
eight-hour
but after three photoshoots I still
haven't been paid anything beyond my
regular hourly rate which is twenty
dollars I remember that I enjoy modeling
but not for free and again I was
originally hired as a retoucher should I
not have agreed to do this in the first
place what do I do
oh hey what a mess
ELISA first of all let me explain
everybody would a retouch or is your
actually modifying photographs of
clothes that's a skill set that's a
talent you're being hired to being paid
20 bucks an hour to do it I get it but
you have a full time job and your boss
has every right to ask you to do things
as an employee nothing wrong with that
you know listen you got a problem you've
already done three shoots and you
haven't even squealed about any of it
you haven't made any noise at all so now
you're in a bit of an under leverage
situation here's the answer if you think
you're worth more as a model why don't
you ask your boss for a bonus for saving
him so much money ask him to give you
two hundred of it
start there accept the hundred if he'll
give it to you it's five times it's five
hours of work for you and you're
building a portfolio if you really want
to pursue modeling but I'm sorry your
boss doesn't owe you anything
not if you didn't bring it up ELISA you
got to take this up with him open your
mouth
start a dialogue see where you can go
it's all about negotiating my friend
I've got a video that came in with a
rather complicated dispute from Maria
hey Kevin we really need your help I run
my family jewelry business with my dad
an internationally acclaimed jewelry
artist who's been named as one of the
most innovative designers of our time
all of our jewelry is handcrafted in the
heart of New York City and we've been
hit very hard with this pandemic
especially with our retail partner
Neiman Marcus declaring chapter 11 we
currently have 80% of our inventory
consigned with them which amounts to
$200,000 that we currently can't get
back we have tried to contact them and
get our inventory back before they
declare chapter 11 but we're unable to I
would greatly appreciate any help and
you getting back to me thank you
look this is completely unfair you tell
you why it's
$200,000 that's serious coin and for her
business probably it means life or death
if she doesn't get that back and turn it
into cash el pronto that's gonna be a
big problem now there's good news here
and bad news right out of the gate the
good news is that inventories on
consignment
which means Maria still owns it it's
hers she lent it to the store until they
sold it bad news this thing is mired in
a bankruptcy now what usually happens in
situations like this as you start making
calls nobody answers you nobody cares
you're one of a thousand people
screaming to get your money back out of
a bankruptcy this is where I can help
one of the great things about being mr.
wonderful is everybody returns my calls
so I picked up the phone and I called
Neiman Marcus and guess what they
returned my call I told a nice man
they're exactly what happened and how
Maria needed her inventory back because
Neiman didn't own it she did and I also
told him I want to put the two of them
together to work it out and of course I
would be checking up in a couple days to
make sure it all worked out I want to
hear the outcome of this so to you so
I've asked Maria to come on I've got her
by video Maria good to see you
look I know 200,000 is huge dollars I
get it tell me what would happen if we
didn't get this inventory back to your
business well it's it's 80% of our
entire inventory so we would have
probably been in a lot of trouble and
most likely business I hate to hear that
now I got you set up with the right
person within the big-box retailer tell
me what happened it's actually
incredible they asked me for all debate
paperwork and it was at my fingertips so
I emailed it to them right away and in
less than a minute the head of jewelry
got in touch with me I apologize for not
getting back to me earlier and they said
that they will make it right and they
will file the appropriate paperwork so
that we can get our collections back
within a few weeks well listen I'm
really happy I could help out here this
is a wonderful outcome you know what se
would say both of us here Maria is you
were meticulous record-keeping without
that I couldn't have helped you that was
the key
great job tracking all this stuff and
making sure you knew where it was that
was brilliant
I couldn't have thank you I really
appreciate that but I'm here to help
that's why I do this we wanted to say a
huge thank you to you and if you come to
New York we would love to see you at art
gallery in Times Square that's very kind
that's very kind Maria anyways thanks a
lot I'm glad I could help
take care stay healthy stay safe see you
soon
thank you so much Kevin I have a video
here from Corrales which is an
incredibly I'd call it interesting and
complex case
hello my name's Corrales I'm a high
school chemistry teacher and an
entrepreneur in Tampa Florida and my
money dispute has to do with having
$18,000 in student loans take it on my
name without my knowledge or consent
it all started freshman year of college
I had a very close family friend that
I've known for a very long time offer to
pay for my college as a gift I trusted
this family friend so of course I said
yes I was thrilled to have the
opportunity to live on campus and to
have this person's help well fast
forward a couple years we had a huge
falling-out a bad falling-out with this
family friend so that's when I took over
my expenses and then I discovered that
$18,000 in student loans has been taken
out of my name without my consent or
knowledge my signature was forged and he
took all the necessary stuff so that
would have been made aware of it I had
tons of contact of that family friend
directly through text and call and never
heard from them again so that's when I
went to file a police report and then I
waited for that investigation and the
case was closed because it went to my
better man so I pretty much lost hope
I'm still paying these student loans
with all the balloon and interest it's
$25,000 that I'm still paying I still
owe $25,000 I don't think it's fair
because I never signed up for this Kevin
can you help me well there's just so
many questions to ask him I had to ask
her Alice to join me it's a crazy story
let's bring her on corrales you there
yeah are you very good listener I got a
million questions
got questions go back tell me what
happened there I need to understand that
so I began college as a freshman and I
had 75% of my tuition already covered
from scholarships I did have some extra
college expenses and a close family
friend said he'd take care of it now
when you said when he said I'll take
care of it you assumed gift he's gonna
give you the money right right
you know Cheers go buy and we have a
falling out with this family friend and
so I took it upon myself to take care of
my college expenses and so I ran my
first credit report and I discovered
that I have eighteen thousand dollars in
student debt you what you weren't in
arrears no so original loan was eighteen
and then the interest accrued up to
twenty-five thousand that's the new
number that's a serious chunk of change
when you're just getting out of college
I make about thirty five thousand a year
and it is going to take me until 2040 so
another 20 years for me to pay off these
loans and I would have paid for eight
thousand 2040 2040 whoa we do not pay
teachers enough this is crazy so then I
went to the police I filed a police
report that you know fraud like I didn't
sign up for the student loans and the
case was closed because it went to my
betterment she wasn't the beneficiary I
was so careless I actually have the
police report let me read it to you this
is what the detective said I contacted
an assistant state attorney in reference
to this incident he advised that the
statute for identity theft states that
the identity theft must have been done
for fraudulent means you were the
beneficiary of this the case of identity
theft does not meet Florida State
statute criteria there you have it and
at that point I kind of just gave up and
I've been making payments because I
don't want to not pay them and then my
credit be harmed can I ask you what you
would have done because you only had 75%
of your tuition paid for would you have
raised the eighteen
thousand another way I don't think I
even would have talked out those loans
to be honest and I'm gonna have lived at
the dorm I mean I I slum it all the time
just to be well-off I wouldn't have live
it at the dorm and I would have hustled
because I'm a hard worker and that's
what I did for the remaining of my
college years right I worked and I paid
for it - all right cross
what do you want and what do you want me
to do um what I want is to not have this
financial burden that I didn't sign up
for I I want to be able to focus on me a
little more because obviously by the
teacher's salary like sorry but I just
didn't sign up for this like I have a
passion to be a teacher and we should be
separate from the decision that someone
else made for me I mean you wouldn't be
knocking on my door seven years later if
this thing really wasn't bugging you he
never told you who's taking these loans
out and he basically did this without
any knowledge that you would now have to
pay them back that was unfair corrales
I'm gonna take a two-pronged approach
I've already reached out to navient the
company that administers your loan and
they sent me back a statement it's
actually good news let me read it to you
we will be reaching out directly to the
borrower we take seriously any
allegation of fraud and investigate
fully talk about opening the door I'm
liking this but when you're dealing with
such a crazy situation you got to figure
out what are your options so I've
actually got an expert
Barry Coleman from the National
Foundation of credit counseling he's an
expert on student loans he'll tell us if
there's anywhere for us to go with this
Barry you understand the situation of
this particular loan you've seen the
details my question is because she was
the beneficiary of all this is there any
way to try and remedy this situation the
one thing that's really bothering me
Barry is by the time she finishes paying
for this she'll have paid $40,000 the
majority of it in interest it seems
unfair when she didn't even know she had
a loan for almost two years what can we
do
sure it certainly seems unfair and
there is a provision of related to
federal student loans where a borrower
may seek relief in these situations and
it's called discharge based on identity
theft or forgeries by third party now
according to the regulations a borrower
is seeking this discharge
must certify that the borrower did not
sign the promissory note corrales you
never signed anything you never saw this
form until years later we're clean right
yeah that's because they never even knew
about it they must also certify that the
borrower did not receive or benefit from
the proceeds of the loan which I know
that's the case here but in the second
part it says with knowledge that the
loan had been made without the
borrower's authorization and so I think
that's a that's a key part of that
particular point in the law that
Corrales appears not to have knowledge
that the loan was made and it was made
without her authorization well there's
nothing to point that she you know was
knowledgeable about it there's no piece
of paper that's a smoking gun yes I
would certainly encourage you to
consider pursuing this discharge by
contacting your federal loan servicer
and taking the next steps they have a
form that you have to fill out in these
situations and then based on that form
and any evidence that you can provide
they will investigate it and make a
determination based on that Barry do you
mind if I connect you directly with
Corrales so you guys can work a little
bit more in this case absolutely you'll
certainly do all we can to assist you
okay Barry you've opened the door I can
see the crack of light I want to thank
both of you first Corrales to have the
bravery to come forward and talk about
this
some people are embarrassed about things
like this they don't want them to
resurface not seven years later they
suffer in silence and pay all that
interest I guess that kind of a lost
hope then I saw you know Kevin with
money to you and I was like oh my
goodness maybe there's hope and it was
actually really hard for me to step out
like this but I just did it I bit the
bullet and I'm like
I'm gonna go for it and you know I
appreciate y'all being here changes that
we happening I feel and I do see the
light and bury the knowledge you've got
gave us that little crack in the door
that maybe we can go solve this
situation with so I thank you for that
it's actually a complex world and you
know I would like to say that the NFC
see we are national nonprofit and you
know we have an FCC certified student
loan counselors that are able to assist
with developing plans to help
individuals take a holistic approach to
addressing their student loans Mary
thank you so much this is just the
beginning of a journey let's see what
happens yeah thank you thank you people
this is why I do the work send a video
to cnbc.com slash money dispute tell me
everything you got and watch me make it
happen for you all right I've got a
dispute coming in from Ken he sent in a
video very interesting situation this
one has leverage I like leverage I like
it when you have a crowbar to start your
dispute mr. wonderful SOS red alert I
need your help in September 2017 I sold
my home and I signed a purchase and sale
agreement for a new home to be
constructed with a completion date of
January 2018 I then moved my family my
wife my two kids and my two golden
retrievers into an apartment well the
home was being constructed
spoiler alert things didn't go as
planned January 2018 February March
April May June July 2018 the house was
not completed at that point asked the
Builder for my thirty four thousand
dollar deposit to be returned to me and
plot twists the Builder said no since
that point in May two thousand nineteen
he sold the house to someone else for
more money than what I was even going to
buy it for so he's made out on the deal
can you give me a strategy of how I can
go about getting my thirty four thousand
dollar deposit back as well as
I've spent more than $15,000 at this
point in litigation trying to get that
deposit back can you help me you've come
to the right place why because you have
leveraged my friend you have a contract
a purchase and sale agreement you know
Ken I'll let you in a little fact most
people do not read their purchase and
sale agreement it's multiple pages it
got a lot of fine print but in this case
you're gonna have to do that because
there's several attributes that may be
built into there like when the home
isn't delivered by a certain date
he starts paying interest on the
deposits you gave him or maybe other
penalties also sometimes they
contemplate legal fees like the 15,000
you've already paid but you have to know
exactly what's in that piece of paper
that is your leverage that contract even
he knows one day he's gonna have to
write that check so he's probably
willing and I'm talking about the
Builder now to go somewhere in the
middle let's do the quick math you've
already spent fifteen thousand dollars
against thirty four thousand that means
you're gonna burn all your profits away
if you continue to litigate you've got
to get them to the table basically call
them and say look I'm gonna keep going I
got a purchase and sale agreement but
it's a hassle for you and me let's meet
for a coffee let's cut a deal music to
the ears of somebody that's stuck under
the leverage of a contract you can't get
away from that that's how America runs
instead of paying you back to thirty
four thousand maybe you suggest
twenty thousand a lot less and you'll
take it now and sign away all the rest
of your rights and you walk away leave
this headache behind you buy another
house buy another dog no don't buy
another dog too or enough but you get my
point that's the solution and the only
reason you might even have this option
is the contract when Trust goes away the
paper comes into play that's what they
say
I love you've got some leverage to work
with here good luck my friend okay we've
got a dispute that was videoed in from
Ben let's have a look at this hi my name
is Ben I'm a 35 year old electrician
father of three young children and a
beautiful wife and basically my dispute
is I started doing side work for my
direct boss
and we've been on a project but we were
gonna flip a house I'm supposed to pay
me $30,000 at the end of it take about
four months and we're going out of here
and a half now and the money amount as
it changed I'm afraid to bring anything
up to him because in the past when I've
done decide to work with them I did
bring up the money because the same type
of thing happened and it affected my pay
at work and how many hours I get at work
so I don't know how to handle it
I'm basically every our spare hour I
have is spent there and I don't see my
kids they only see my wife and it has
strained our relationship and I just I
guess I need some guidance Ben Ben Ben
Ben Ben Ben Ben you've come to the right
place this is a mess you my friend are
working for free now if you want to be
in a charity that's fine but this is not
a charity you're actually losing paid
hours to go work for the guy that pays
you for free at his own house you know
it's wrong your wife knows it's wrong
your family knows it's wrong it's got to
be fixed Ben the only way that you can
deal with this is come to a place in
your head and after having talked with
your wife about this that if you can't
resolve this with your boss in a
sit-down conversation you are willing to
walk away people that are willing to
walk away have a lot of power it
empowers you you have to be ready to
leave this ridiculous situation and what
I consider an abusive relationship now
here's what we're gonna do
step one confrontation with the boss has
to be doesn't have to be negative it's
got to be the truth you can't keep doing
this tell them that you want to be paid
for all your hours because he basically
got a good electrician for free count
your hours that you actually did all
that work at take the same rate that you
work for him it's a job and apply that
to what you did at the house I'd like to
know what that number is but you have to
know if he doesn't give you any
compensation at all for the work done in
the private house you can't stay there
the world is telling you to go get
another job that's exactly what's
happening so be prepared tell your wife
your
you're gonna go talk to him if he says
go pound sand I think the world would
treat you well because you're a nice guy
and I'm going to make the assumption
you're a great electrician you just move
on sometimes in life you got to take the
risky prickly path and that's what this
one is been good luck to you I really
feel for you my friend you're a good guy
and this is just wrong I've got a video
from a me and I've getting so many just
like this video oh my goodness
I feel for these people hi my name is
Amy and I am a parent I say middle
school here in Miami Florida the reason
why I'm reaching out for help today is
because on March 15 the students were
supposed to take a trip to Washington DC
with a well-known nonprofit organization
because of the virus because oh come on
a virus the trip was first postponed and
then later on canceled now this is an
eighth grade trip the students will be
moving from middle school to high school
next year so it's not a trip that we can
reschedule it's not really an option for
us well we are asking which give us a
full refund of what we paid in my case I
paid a thousand five hundred and fifty
five dollars but I know that there's
some parents that ended up paying a
little bit more than that I think it's
only fair and it's only right for a
nonprofit organization to give us back
100 percent refund Amy here's the
problem this is not a for-profit
business this is a charity basically
that's trying to make great experiences
happen for kids in middle school their
altruistic they're not after you to make
money what's probably happened here Amy
is they've already spent money just
organizing the trip that money is gone
so here's what you're going to do you're
going to write a letter to every member
of the board of that nonprofit and
because it's a non-profit and its public
you can get that information off their
website everybody on that board is going
to get the same letter and they're going
to know that everybody else got the
letter you're powerful Amy letter is
power you're going to explain right out
of the gate that you wrote a check
expecting to send your child to
Washington the pandemic it didn't happen
you don't want a credit it's useless to
you and the rest of the families because
your children are moving on they can't
use it so you understand
in the letter you're going to say that
the nonprofit probably spent some money
setting it up you don't expect that back
you're willing to take less than a
hundred cents on the dollar but you want
the rest I think you're gonna find out
they'll give you whatever cash is still
there and I think that's a fair outcome
to this situation Amy good luck I've got
a business question from a Kitty's name
is August it's an email let's check it
out I'm a kid mowing lawns I have a
50-50 partnership with the other kid
next door even though I do all the
bookkeeping and everything else outside
mowing the problem I want out I have no
control over our schedule because I
always have to wait for him to finish
baseball practice before we can mow I
want to be paid extra for the
bookkeeping but he refuses because he
says he could do it all - except he
doesn't owe I feel the tension I want to
be paid extra for the pickup truck I
bought for the business but he says it's
my truck and has nothing to do with him
how do I end this thing just so you know
our estimated 2020 revenues is $20,000
oh yeah you got a business kiddo and you
got problems to your partner let me
explain something about partnerships
August when you form a partnership with
somebody and this could be in business
or in life a like your wife maybe you
are forming a bond you are forming a
relationship and it's based on a 50-50
idea now what you're complaining about
is your partner's letting you down not
carrying half the weight but that
doesn't mean you can just walk away if
you want to end this thing with him you
got to buy him out
you're making twenty thousand dollars
maybe you're gonna give him five of it
and it's sayonara if he says no you know
what you do talk to his parents explain
the situation that their son is not
cooperating with you but you want to do
the right thing help them mediate a deal
your reputation is everything
August remember this kid is your next
door neighbor so how you handle is
everything he's not going away he's
living right beside you you want to wake
up the morning after
and the relationship in the business and
still have them is your neighbor and a
friend once that's over with
go find another partner and build the
business you keep doing the books you
keep doing the marketing and you hire
other people to mow the lawns now that's
what I'm talking about and I know you've
got it because you're already making
$20,000 you're doing way better than the
guy that used to deliver papers 20,000
bucks you can make it a hundred and
twenty thousand you make it two hundred
and fifty thousand you need to lever
yourself you're an entrepreneur my
friend I want you to go make it happen
all right I've got a video from Joran
and this is about love and mr. wonderful
loves love that's why I'm in the wedding
business you know two times in life
where you don't care about margins or
price when you get married when you die
I'm in both businesses love them oh well
let's hear from joint
hello mr. wonderful I went and I bought
a ring for my girlfriend to become my
fiancee and I'm trying to be quiet
because she's right upstairs so you know
Shh don't tell her but um I went in
bought a ring spent 6,500 bucks on it
jeweler claims he never got the payment
I have bank statements saying that it
was taken check was cash
accepted is sixty five hundred bucks
make or break money you know not to
everybody but it's the principle of me
not being able to call my girlfriend my
fiancee and just calling her my
girlfriend I hope you know how truly
blessed I am to have this woman in my
life and I'd do anything to buy her a
ring if it's another sixty five hundred
bucks I gotta spend I'm I'd spend it
every day the week because I love her
that much but I'm wanted to send you
this video letting you know what was
going on and I can't wait to hear a
response from you I love the fact you're
putting love over money there's only one
time in your life when you can do that
when you're falling in love it's so
euphoric it's so wonderful I feel great
for you on that now let's talk about the
dispute three things you're gonna do
right now since your fiancee down tell
her the whole story you know great
weddings have mystique and miss mystery
to them and you've got a heck of a story
here you basically bought her a ring in
good faith and never got delivery I
think that's gonna be a story you're
gonna tell your grandchildren that's
fantastic and still you got married and
still you're together
that's the hopeful outcome number
- let's talk about the money you're
going to send a letter into their
customer complaint department with all
your information including the canceled
check and say you've never got delivery
some employee in there is gonna try and
figure it out believe me they don't want
to defraud people because you're also
gonna say in that complaint if you don't
get results within a week you're gonna
go public with it and you're gonna start
posting all over the place that this
company basically stole from you that's
fair to say one way another you're
getting your money back is just a matter
of time but really what I hope is this
ends up lamode a whoa whoa whoa whoa I
love love that's why they call me mr.
wonderful we've got a question for
Jordan here which is I think a question
a lot of people are going to relate to
it's happening all over America hey
Kevin Jordan from new jersey here how
are you huge fan I am in a dispute with
my gym I spent $900 on painting sessions
and then this coronavirus happened the
gyms been closed for two months and they
won't give me my money back I'd be fine
with a we're so sorry i trough tough
times here's an extra four sessions when
we reopen fine I would take it very
happy to tell me that you're not giving
me a refund just emails me back it is
like no no no no no no like that is so
nasty and I can't take when businesses
take advantage of the situation and
they're not customer focused Kevin I
need your help with this I'm in a huge
go fluffle with this place please help
Jordan I can't stand nasty cough offals
as you call it and surely there's got to
be a resolution to this let's be
pragmatic the guy's running a gym
operation nobody could see the pandemic
coming I get that you probably have no
contract because this is really a
relationship between a trainer and you
in a gym I'm going to guess that so
basically this is about what's fair for
the business proprietors the trainers
you got to be fair you got to offer your
time and service to your clients and
they will not forget Jordans not going
to forget if you do that they're gonna
make sure that they work with you going
forward because you cared about them at
a time when they couldn't work with you
directly in a gym so I reached out to
your gym and
they got back to me let me tell you what
they said it's good news my friend all
clients have been offered the
opportunity to train virtually with
their trainer to use the sessions while
we are closed or they can use them in
person when we reopen they will get the
service that they paid for Jordan that's
a key we are hoping for an early June
reopening hey Jordan they didn't offer
your money back but they did offer the
service and one way to resolve this
thing is you simply ask for a couple
more virtual lessons that would seem
fair to me the point is they're willing
to meet in the middle and that's a good
thing I think this is a good outcome
okay I have a question from Jason here
and this one's a toughy I'm a commercial
landlord but I only own two properties
so when tenants don't pay it causes huge
problems for me yeah I totally get that
totally get that that's cash flow well
one tenant is a gigantic nationwide
chain I wonder who that could be and
their corporate office just sent a
letter stating that due to kovat 19
they're going to stop paying full rent
as of June 1st hmm I think it's insane
that a huge corporation is trying to
shift its burden onto a little guy like
me I know that if I take them to court
I'd most likely win but I can't afford
it what do I do
Jason my friend I'm dealing with 51
companies I'm an investor in 29 of which
are in disputes with landlords I'm
seeing both sides of this issue everyday
and dealing with it it's really hard but
let me give you some immediate advice
here having gone through it so many
times well you have to be very genteel
in how you deal with this situation do
you really want to bite the hand that
feeds you think about it they're
basically asking you probably to defer
the rent in other words they have no
traffic they have no income and if you
were to negotiate with them and say look
it's unfair to me to take on the entire
economic burden can I extend the lease
or at least three months or what could
we meet halfway
or anything in between is better than
saying I'm going to sue you
not a good idea of its a national chain
so in this case here's what's going to
happen number one you're going to write
let her back saying thank you for
informing me of this but you're putting
me under stress because I'm a small guy
and I've been a great landlord to you
that's number one number two you're
going to make a suggestion of where
you'd meet in the middle number three
and make sure you put this in there that
you've appreciated having as a tenant
and you look forward for better times
they'll understand what you're saying
there that is the right thing to do here
but don't just sit in silence
contemplating litigation not a good idea
don't sue the hand that feeds you
remember I said that and good luck to
you alright I have a question in videoed
from Suzanne on a very complex issue
have a listen this is my story I have
three products I developed just me no
business partners no rich husbands and
Malibu financing anything just me the
first products on the market selling
great second and third products I wanted
to try and get a patent on so I hide a
patent attorney she suggested and it
seemed quite common sense to do a patent
search to see yes or no would there be
any reason on the market why these
patents would be tonight so I did that
and the results came back saying it
looks good so let's do it fast forward
two years both patent applications
denied reject it and this is what I
found out there is a law a very small
but important law that if any product is
advertised or sold 12 months prior to a
patent application the application is
invalid they just deny it flat out
now you would think as a patent attorney
she would know this and she would advise
as legal counsel any people that she was
representing so I don't know she's
either a complete scam artist or
completely incompetent either which way
no way no but I would love my money back
I work really hard for my money and it's
not a lot of money to a lot of people
but it's a lot of money to me so please
how I write Suzanne very interesting
case here in a nutshell you're telling
me basically your attorney went and
pursued a patent even though it would
have been very easy to find out prior
art or commercial as you said happen to
earlier to me that sounds like
incompetence to me it sounds like they
tried to milk you with fees that's what
it sounds like if what you've told me is
correct you've got a very interesting
case here so here's what's gonna happen
the only path you have unless you want
to spend a lot of time and money in
litigation which the outcome is never
clear is to simply write a letter that
contains this you detail on that letter
exactly what you told me on this date I
called you and hired you to pursue a
patent you told me you were going to do
prior art search that's what it's called
you blatantly missed a commercial only
12 months old which never happens I feel
that you have really taken advantage of
me as a small business and it's not
right and then suggest what would make
you happy and make you go away as
somebody that's going to be a combatant
or complaint
I would ask 50% of my money back and be
happy if I got that by the way Suzanne
that's a three paragraph letter don't
make it any longer than that it's that
simple to put that out there and then
call them up a week later and ask them
what do they want to do because this is
not right
it just isn't I have a question from
Denise and this is very interesting I
think you're going to have to follow me
through the different levels of the
onion on this one ready here we go
I'm gonna go slowly so you stay with me
this is about a golf cart I feel I
should inherit my mother-in-law quote
unquote
was dating my brother-in-law's dad
brother-in-law's dad okay but after she
died and left behind her golf cart
my brother-in-law kept it because he
said he put a new battery in it and was
going to use it that's the setup
he said she wanted to have it but in
fact he hated her and always talked
about her behind her back I'm now not
even speaking with my sister because of
this they're rich enough to buy 12 golf
carts and we are not what is your advice
well I'm fascinated I mean there's a lot
going on here there's clearly family
there's a golf cart there's capital
expenditures in a new battery on the
golf cart but
I understand fair is fair you thought
you'll promise the golf cart and now you
have a family member that said no I'm
not giving it to you all right let's try
put a value on this thing it's a used
golf cart with a new battery what's that
worth if it was the rolls-royce of golf
carts maybe 2500 in reality on this one
500 bucks maybe
is it really worth fighting about I
don't think so this isn't a child it's a
golf cart you know I love hearing from
you about all and any financial conflict
and I want to keep hearing from you
so visit cnbc.com slash money dispute
and please upload a video I can't wait
to see you and until then stay healthy
and take care
[Music]